donc je m'appelle laurent tolzac et je
vais mettre un petit disque est mort je
vais essayer de vous donner une cet
après midi une perspective
franco/néo-zélandaise
est forcément venant de nouvelle zélande
j'ai un petit peu de des anglicismes
donc je me moquais à l'époque de jean
claude van damme mais il y aura quelques
mots anglais qui vont se glisser dans le
soyez indulgents avec moi
on a à peu près 15 minutes pour parler
des algorithmes et derrière la dent
pendant la conversation avec brio en
fait il ya eu la question de est ce que
il faut en avoir peur ou pas alors je
vais vous proposer un petit panorama et
puis je vais vous répondre par oui mais
non mais ben je vous donnerai quelques
références par la suite
alors c'est toujours bien de parler du
nouveau avec des anciens et là en
l'occurrence et aristote et aristote
qu'est ce qu'il a dit il a dit que
l'habitude est une seconde nature donc
fait retenez bien cette phrase parce que
je vais y revenir un peu plus tard dans
la présentation et aristote a aussi dit
que la définition fait connaissent ce
qu'est la chose donc plus on connaît les
choses - en fait on en a peur aussi
quelques pas et ça tombe bien puisque en
deuxième partie
c'est quoi un algo alors je vous invite
aussi à voir de nouveau le tedx de
rennes 2 arnaud et jérôme qui est
vraiment excellent aux excellents pardon
et la première chose aussi c'est pas un
algo ce sont des algues au des
algorithmes et alors c'est quoi un
algorithme en fait c'est très simple
c'est un procédé c'est une méthode pour
atteindre un objectif ou réaliser
quelque chose donc c'est une suite est
généralement mathématiques ou
informatique alors quand on regarde la
définition de l'inria ils prennent comme
exemple une recette alors par exemple on
peut parler du du saucisson brioché par
exemple et donc dans ces cas là pour
faire du saucisson brioché il faut du
saucisson il faut de la brioche et pour
faire un saucisson faut faire une suite
de séquences de procéder pour avoir du
saucisson donc je vous laisse je vous
laisse comprendre ça une autre façon
aussi c'est de regarder un mot dans le
dictionnaire on regarde la première
lettre on va la page car la deuxième
lettre ensuite tout un processus
d'accord donc c'est un processus
linéaire
la deuxième définition qui est un peu
plus un port un intéressante pour nous
ce sont les algorithmes autos 1 prenant
donc machine learning algorithmes et là
alors c'est un peu plus compliqué et le
la cnil en fait et samuel
utilise un exemple c'est le bébé qui est
devant sa boîte à forme et qui va
prendre un cercle et puis qui va le
mettre dans un car et il va le faire
plusieurs fois et les parents vont être
dépité forcément puisqu'il n'y arrivera
pas du premier coup mais quand même va
se passer quelque chose chez l'enfant il
va à touba pour retourner la boîte et
puis il va essayer de mettre ça je sais
pas dans un triangle ou dans une étoile
il y arrivera toujours pas jusqu'au
moment où ta dah à la joie des parents
il arrivera à faire son ca formeront
dans la forme ronde et là
si ils y arrivent du premier coup la
prochaine fois c'est qu'il a appris
quelque chose donc il ya une notion de
tâches en fonction
de la performance et qui est réalisé en
fait par rapport à l'expérience et les
algorithmes hauteur apprenant les
machine learning ont cette capacité à
apprendre de ces répétitions et de dire
ben là maintenant pour augmenter la
productivité je peux faire cette façon
de cet âge de cette façon beaucoup plus
simple sans que personne ne met rien dit
je lui ai appris tout seul
et là où je voudrais aussi
demander votre votre indulgence ce que
j'ai je parmi tous les définitions et
les livres que j'ai regardé moi j'ai une
définition de l'alcôve plus ce que
j'appelle la go plus et qui est aussi
basé sur l'institut des hautes études
pour la science et la technologie qui
dit en fait que
en fait un algorithme c'est un objet
c'est une équation mathématique c'est un
système informatique mais il faut pas
simplement le regarder comme un outil il
faut le contextualiser il faut savoir
qu'ils utilisent comme on le nourrit et
et dans quel contexte aussi on
l'appliqué donc il ya cette dimension un
peu plus humaine et là il ya une notion
de complicité qui vient ça va abaisser
des trois choses différentes
alors faut-il en avoir peur ben oui il
faut en avoir peur parce qu'il ya une
espèce de d'extrême rationalisation du
processus informatiques et mathématiques
de notre société ou des choses
et puis en plus les gens qui vous diront
ça ils vous diront oui mais une machine
c'est beaucoup plus fiable qu'un être
humain et ils ont raison d'une certaine
façon
mais d'un autre côté je vous prends deux
exemples dans la santé une des
conséquences du diabète c'est que on
peut perdre la juge en fait ça peut
créer une cécité et google en 2016 il me
semble à regarder comment on peut
détecter en fait cette cécité comment on
peut prévenir faire la médecine
préventive par rapport à des images des
scanners de la rétine et donc ils se
sont posés sur la question et en deux
ans ou trois ans plus tard
verrilli la branche santé deux alphabets
c'est à dire le google santé qu en gros
a déjà défini tout un protocole ici de
machine learning pour en fait scanner la
rétine dire attention la dilatation des
vaisseaux l'hémorragie ici et là et là
ça va entraîner telles conséquences et
donc on peut prévenir donc ça c'est une
des applications qui est très bien par
les mathématiques l'autre application
qui vient de ce rapport là c'est on
parle de véhicules autonomes donc faut
calculer les distances etc vous savez
très bien roulé mais si vous pouviez
voir 20 kilomètres à l'avant sont
fonction des conditions climatiques ou
des embouteillages ou des travaux sur la
route est ce que ça vous
vous aiderez pas non plus à mieux
prendre un chemin ou de prendre de
meilleures décisions finalement grâce à
une machine qui pourra vous prévenir de
choses que vous ne pouvez pas voir ou ne
pas connaître à l'avancé
donc voilà alors non faut pas en avoir
peur
c'est ce que j'ai un petit peu de vous
dire mais en même temps il ya il ya
siboni qui parle en fait que l'homme
deux choses qui sont importantes c'est
l'expérience et l'intuition et
l'expérience alors moi je la questionne
puisque profère une tâche 800 fois pour
une machine n'y a pas de problème pour
une personne ya la fatigue des
interprétations voilà il ya des choses
comme ça par contre là tu sion
cela pour l'instant une machine n'arrive
pas à la voir c'est des choses qui sont
assez magique pour l'instant donc
je voudrais vous montrer l'autre côté
aussi des algorithmes c'est que je sais
pas si vous êtes au courant
l'année dernière il ya eu un problème
par rapport au système de santé
américain qui a mis d'une façon
expérimentale certains processus en
fonction de ce que vous regarder à la
télévision ce que vous consommez donc
surtout du legends diabétiques les gens
qui ont par exemple du cholestérol les
gens qui font pas d'exercice ben ces
gens là ils se sont vu augmenter leur
leur sécurité sociale angot l'heure
leur assurance maladie parce qu'il ne
remplissait pas les cases et que parce
que il ya aussi votre smart watch qui a
dit vous n'avez pas fait les 12000 pas
par jour donc demain vous allez payer 15
euros de plus votre assurance santé donc
vous voyez que ce que ça peut créer un
petit peu comme comme problème en dehors
de des riches qui vont pouvoir se payer
leur assurance santé il ya aussi des
problèmes d'éthique un petit peu quelque
part et de société et je pense que vous
la connaissez francis hogan qui est
juste ici qui a dénoncé facebook dénonce
pas mal de choses mais ce qui est
surtout intéressant où ce qui m'a
interpellé c'est deux choses c'est lé
biais cognitif qu'on a sur les à cause
des algorithmes donc je prends l'exemple
des des adolescents ce moment qu en
confinement qui sont un petit peu
perdues alors ils vont chercher des
témoignages ils ont cliqué sur les trucs
qui parlent de choses comme ils vont se
reconnaître c'est super je suis pas seul
du coup ça rassure un petit peu à court
terme mais à long terme la force de voir
des gens qui sont déprimés qu'ils sont
déprimés qu'ils sont des prix fait ça ça
plombe un petit peu le moral ça des
effets sur la santé mentale et quelque
part en fait ça sur les planches dans la
dépression voire certains jusqu'au
suicide donc enfin si cela dit attention
et 26 dit aussi bine facebook il a
maintenant saturé le marché et qu'est ce
qui se passe c'est qu'ils les prochains
cliente facebook ce sont les enfants
donc on va mettre des algorithmes qui
vont plaire aux enfants et vous voyez
tous les problèmes éthiques qui peut y
avoir derrière ça et le libre arbitre
des enfants qui n'est absolument pas là
voilà donc il faut en avoir peur faut
pas en avoir peur
ben voilà donc dans un monde idéal on
devrait faire coexister l'intelligence
humaine et l'intelligence artificielle
et en nouvelle zélande j'ai eu la chance
de travailler avec ibm qui qui parle dia
au sens d'intelligence
augmenter et non pas artificiel
et j'aime bien cette définition là parce
qu'en fait on assiste l'humain on garde
un humain au centre des décisions mais
on les augmente de certaines capacités
informatiques mathématiques grâce à des
processus qui sont soit linéaire soit
non linéaire par les algorithmes
un exemple concret c'est emma bid qui
regardaient les algorithmes des rétines
dauphin de scan de rétina vent qui
fonctionnait très bien san francisco en
laboratoire de google
mais qui une fois déployée en thaïlande
ne fonctionnait plus aussi bien le taux
de réussite à san francisco était de 95%
il est beaucoup il est tombé beaucoup
plus bas en thaïlande et elle est ainsi
demandé comment ça se fait en fait
comment ça se fait ça se fait que en
thaïlande ils n'ont pas les mêmes
machines gke aux etats unis ils n'ont
pas les mêmes experts que des causes
états unis il ne calibre pas aussi
souvent que aux états unis parce qu'ils
n'ont pas forcément les moyens pour
calibrer la machine et les ingénieurs
qui gère la machine ne sont peut-être
pas aussi pointu
au public comme on dit à niveau ou que
aux états unis alors elle a dit ben
voilà il faut faire attention comment on
nourrit l'algorithme est est ce que
maintenant on peut simplement garder le
même algorithme et lui donner des images
un peu moins de un peu plus pixelisé de
moins haute définition un peu plus floue
et est-ce que ça va résoudre le problème
et oui ça l'a résolu qu'en fait donc
s'améliorer au niveau des pronostics ça
je vais pas vous en parler c'est
concernant le cancer de la peau
mais un autre domaine qui est
intéressant c'est est ce que vous
connaissez la bbc ns
non personne
c'est l'équivalent un petit peu de
spotify de saint-claude la différence
c'est que c'est entièrement gratuit ça
et là on a
vite à aura une pop ce chanteuse
anglaise qui va jouer sa musique sa
chanson etc mais si vous écoutez
bbc size
l'application l'algorithme et va vous
dire mais est ce que tu sais qu'il ya
une interview de rita ici qu'on a fait
aussi alors tout d'un coup vous avez
peut-être écouté saï saï ça donc ça va
vous donner des choses qui sont un petit
peu en dehors de purement la chanson
qu'on pourrait trouver sur sur spotify
donc là aussi l'ordinateur peut
peut-être ou l'algorithme peut vous
assister dans vos décisions ou
découverte de nouvelles choses
et il ya eu un mouvement aussi qui
soutient cette façon de cette approche
un petit peu de d'augmenter les
capacités humaines ça s'appelle
l'ingénieur critique qui a été fondée en
2011 c'est un manifesto qui ans qui en
ligne et ça c'est 6e le sixième
amendement du manifesto qui dit en fait
que l'objet mathématique en lui-même
faut faire super attention faut bien
faire attention au réseau dans lequel il
est utilisé avec quelle machine il va
communiquer dans quel contexte il va
être appliquée et quels sont les gens
qui vont aussi lire la data ou qu'ils
vont comprendre les données derrière
d'accord
donc voilà et cerise sur le gâteau au
niveau de l'assistance
là ce sont deux compagnies
d'investissement d'ypf knowledge venture
à un algorithme je vais vous expliquer
mieux avec hong kong vicié mais à un
algorithme qui s'appelle vital même
assez croustillants comme nom pour un
algorithme il ya d'autres algorithmes
qui s'appelle einstein ou des choses
comme ça c'est assez rigolo et met par
exemple chez encore vie seuil
ils ont alors ils ont un conseil
d'administration de six personnes sur
les six personnes il ya une machine un
algorithme on lui demande de regarder
les marchés on lui demande de regarder
les investissements on le branche sur
sur des bancs etc et lorsqu'il faut
prendre une décision d'un conseil
d'administration on lui demande sa voix
mais ça représente 15 % des votes une
machine sur cinq personnes qui vont en
fait décidé donc vous voyez quand même
que l'algorithme ça peut être un ses
intérêts de temps et puis alors je vous
ai dit tout à l'heure que nous étions
des habitudes enfin des créatures
d'habitude les algorithmes c'est
simplement une routine aussi donc vous
quand vous allumez votre ordinateur
quand vous allumez votre téléphone c'est
une routine tous les matins vous
regardez votre truc vous allez aux
toilettes tous les matins vous prenez
votre café d'une certaine façon vous
avez votre vos routines donc certaine
routine sont bonnes après certaines
notre routine sont peut-être moins bonne
alors ça ce sont les références là ce
sont essentiellement des articles qui
sont plus lents à lire mais mais qui
sont très intéressants qui vous donne
plus de détails que ce que j'ai fait
puisqu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps les
références dans les slides c'est surtout
par rapport aux images que j'ai
sélectionné pour les droits d'auteur les
définitions que je vous ai donné elles
sont basées sur trois livres qui sont
intéressants dont celle de derrick qui
un peu pessimiste mais jean marc et
évelyne appartiennent ce que je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure li h e st
et ils ont fait un bon panorama de de
toutes les dernières trouvailles puisque
sa date de cette année sur les
algorithmes quant à aurélie elle amène
une perspective qui est très
intéressante surtout en plus
avec sa sensibilité féminine c'est de
dire finalement pour pas être victime
des algorithmes me faudrait peut-être
que nous tous on apprenne à coder
comprendre le code et la place d'être
passif par rapport à cela qu'on puisse
le hacker qu'on puisse le déformer ou
l'adapter en fonction de nos besoins
là il ya aussi le
massachusetts institute of technology et
mighty ki qui offre pas mal de thèmes
ici je voulais choisir là j'ai choisi
massif mais machine mining parce que
c'est le thème d'aujourd'hui mais c'est
très intéressant donc documentez-vous et
en france on a cette collection les
éditions des archives contemporaines qui
est entièrement gratuite qui a plein de
thèmes super intéressant je vous
conseille vraiment de d'accéder alors à
leur collection c'est vraiment très très
intéressant donc plus on sait aussi ce
que disait aristote aussi puis on arrive
à définir les choses puis on les
comprend moins dans la peur et peut-être
aussi plus on peut agir en fonction de
ces choses là
alors ça c'est un petit un petit clin
d'oeil qui déjà vu ou au lit
87 3% de la seule là
on bat des records donc ça donne quand
même de 2008 quand même c'est pas tout
jeune et alors moi je vous conseille de
regarder ou au lit pour trois raisons 1
ça fait un portrait de la nature humaine
profonde qui est assez intéressant 2 ça
parle de ce fameux mythe du contrôle des
machines sur les humains mais d'une
façon beaucoup plus intéressante que
terminator et sarah connor et 3 cela
parle bien avant l'heure de tous ces
problèmes d'écologie de recyclage etc
donc je vous invite même si la majorité
de la salle à vue ou olic de regarder le
nouveau sous cette perspective là d'une
critique très avant gardiste de notre
société donc en 2008 ça fait plus 13 ans
maintenant que ça a été fait
d'accord donc pour les plus intéressés
je vous laisse cinq secondes pour
scanner une présentation
bien il ya une personne intéressée draps
sales c'est bien 2 3
merci pour votre indulgence si le
premier com
et c'est bon on met ce loin et voilà
merci rester positif
[Applaudissements]